اخر تطورات القصف وكذلك الاشتباكات في
خانيونس
نعم محمد الغارات الاسرائيليه لازالت
متواصله على مختلف المناطق في مدينه خان
يونس وتحديدا في منطقه البلد وسط المدينه
قبل قليل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
شنت غاره جويه استهدفت يبدو مربعا سكنيا
او تجاريا في تلك المنطقه وتصاعدت اعمده
دخان كثيف منها نتيجه الغارات الاسرائيليه
الى جانب استمرار الغارات الجويه والقصف
المدفعي على مختلف المناطق في مدينه
خانيونس وتحديدا كما تشاهدون الان استمرار
تصاعد اعمده الدخان من محيط بلده القراره
الى الشمال الشرقي من مدينه خانيونس نتيجه
تواصل القصف الاسرائيلي على هذه المنطقه
ومحيطها منذ ساعات الفجر وحتى هذه اللحظه
حيث تدور اشتباكات اشتباكات بين المقاومه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
في المحورين الشمالي الشرقي وايضا الجنوبي
الشرقي من مدينه خان يونس بقذائف الهون
الى جانبي استهداف الاليات وتمركزات جنود
الاحتلال في محيط منطقه البلد وسط مدينه
خان يونس اليوم اللافت هو استشهاد ثلاثه
فلسطينيين برصاص قناصه من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اثنين منهم في منطقه البلد وسط
مدينه خانيونس واخر استشهد ايضا في منطقه
قيزان النجار في محيط كليه العلوم العلوم
والتكنولوجيا نتي برصاص قناص اسرائيلي
بالاضافه الى استمرار القصف المدفعي على
مختلف المناطق في المدينه والذي لا يتوقف
حقيقه محمد على مدار الساعات الماضيه وحتى
هذه
اللحظه
ايضا الاشتباكات تدور في محيط منطقه البلد
ومحاولات تقدم اسرائيليه الى هذه المنطقه
على وجه التحديد من خلال شارع القسام
بالاضافه الى استهداف حي الامل بقذائف
صاروخيه من قبل مدفعيه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وايضا عمليات تجريف تقوم بها
اليات وجرافات جيش الاحتلال في منطقه
قيزان النجار ما نلاحظه هو محاولات
مواطنين الدخول والوصول الى منطقه البلد
منذ ساعات الصباح لكن هناك تمركزات
للقناصه من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
الابنيه المرتفعه في محيط منطقه منقه
البلد تستهدف كل من يحاول الوصول الى تلك
المنطقه بالرصاص الحي والمباشر فيما لا
تستطيع طواقم الاسعاف او حتى مواطنين
بجهود فرديه ذاتيه الوصول الى تلك المنطقه
لانتشال جثامين الشهداء نتحدث عن انتشار
العشرات من جثامين الشهداء في مختلف
المناطق في مدينه خان يونس ولا تستطيع
طواقم الاسعاف الفلسطينيه سواء التابعه
للهلال الاحمر او وزاره الصحه الوصول
اليها عائله عبد الغفور لوحدها 36 شهيدا
بينهم اطفال في منطقه السطر الغربي
استشهدوا منذ اكثر من 40 يوما ولا يستطيع
الصليب الاحمر التنسيق من خلال جيش
الاحتلال لتمكين طواقم الاسعاف من الوصول
الى تلك المنطقه لانتشال جثامين الشهداء
بالاضافه الى شهداء اخرين لازالوا ملق
ملقون على الارض في منطقه البلد وفي منطقه
ايضا قيزان النجار التي تتعرض منذ ايام
لغارات جويه وقصف مدفعي يستهدف منازل
المواطنين الى جانب العشرات من العائلات
لازالت محاصره داخل منازلها سواء في حاره
زعرب في وسط مدينه خانيونس او حتى منطقه
قيزان النجار لا يمكن الوصول اليهم من
خلال الصليب الاحمر وفرق الانقاذ لاجلاء
من تلك المنطقه وسط مناشدات بان داخل هذه
المنازل يوجد اعداد كبيره من الجرحى لا
يمكن الوصول اليهم واجلاهم الى مستشفى
ناصر لتقديم العلاج اللازم لهم